only on CBS this morning we went with
little Nozick's as he traveled back to
his hometown of Atlanta for the first
time since his record-breaking success
you know he's huge the past couple of
months have been a world win for the
famous rapper whose real name by the
ways Montero Hill he said he chose
little nas X because he thought that
that would attract more attention well
as hit Old Town Road made billboard
history he released his EP 7 he's
performed around the world and now the
20 year old he's just 20 says he's
finally ready to take well a little time
off we were with him as he made a
surprise visit to his Atlanta area high
school what do you think your parents
got that name from Montero Lamar Hill oh
it is embarrassing I had a Mitsubishi
Montero back in the day well that's it
were you named after the car really I
really was and it was only two years ago
little nas ex was a student right here
at Lithia Springs High School during
this surprise visits the students cheer
posed for pictures some even cry for
them his success represents possibility
one little girl said you give me hope to
chase my dreams were you a good student
in high school I was a good student I
mean I was a class clown but I was still
a good student definitely wasn't so long
ago that you were sitting in that school
sitting behind those desks so what did
that mean to you to go back there I
definitely felt like some kind of hero
in a way I guess cuz everybody was just
going crazy
I was dreaming that last year around
this time I would make a huge footprint
in music and I would get up there as
quick as I could and I wouldn't have to
wait as long as other people would
that's honestly like was my goal yeah so
then the song hits the radio it's
climbing up the charts of the Billboard
country charts and then you get the news
that they've decided it's not country
and
mm-hmm and what do you think when you
hear that I'm at a moment of my life
where everything's like you know going
good so I'm just counting my blessings
and I'm just like hmm then you know I
guess I take a peek at some of the other
songs on the country chart obviously I
have hip-hop influence in them I'm very
impressed with you that you weren't hurt
by it or upset by it I mean I could see
how anybody else would be upset but it's
like you're talking to somebody who's
been sleeping on the floors for the past
couple of months trying to get some kind
of song to move this is the least of my
worries pretty much so you have this hit
song but you also in the middle of all
this decide that you're going to come
out I'm curious about what you were
taught about homosexuality when you were
growing up what were you told if you did
like anything like slightly feminine
it's like you know I don't do that gate
you know so you know just like growing
up you see it it's not okay did you know
as a little boy did you were gay
definitely I knew you know I was just
like you know pray and pray and pray and
what were you praying for that it was
like a phase yeah I guess around maybe
16 17 I'm good with this yeah you know
and you were okay with it yeah but I was
like you know of course but I'm not
gonna tell anybody
yeah ever I'm good with it but I'm not
gonna tell anybody
yeah yeah I mean cuz me being in this
position like it's easy for me but like
some little boy 10 miles from here
and nearly like you know like it's not
it's not gonna be good for him yeah but
don't you think you coming out could
probably help others who were struggling
the way you were struggling with it I
think he's gonna always help you know
it's gonna you still have a long way to
go
I'm curious about how you're handling
famed are you scared of it
are you enjoying it I mean I feel like
once I get to my home my apartment
this all feels like I'm in
same place what do you mean like of
course like when you go out a virus like
Oh proud of you congratulations I love
you I love your music I love your song
did you see this video of my daughter
dancing yeah within you like you get to
a quiet space and it's just like
everything's kind of the same I guess
there's somebody who was last year I
can't get over you at your sister's
house sleeping on the floor you know in
addition to having the highest played
song ever ever ever on Billboard when
they tell you that what does that mean
to you
honestly means like anything for anybody
and it's like a cliche thing to say but
like it really is like it can happen for
you it's like if there's gonna be a song
one day that passes days it could be the
song that's released tomorrow it could
be a song it came out five months ago
this is like anything and everything is
like possible yeah he really he's a very
very smart young man he also engages in
strategic that he did a lot of social
media to put the song out but just think
the last six seven months he's at Taco
Bell something called zapped me that zas
bees what is it Zach's piece Zaxby's
Zaxby's it's a chicken restaurant
thank you very much Alexis and he worked
at Six Flags running the rides and he
said he quit all of that so he could
devote everything to making his music he
wanted a quick climb it doesn't come in
any quicker than oh I know and you know
it's funny his dad he's very close to
his father and his parents and he said
that his dad was teasing him about you
need to get better and signing your
autograph your your handwriting is very
very bad his dad is also a very good
singer when you hear to talk about what
he wanted to do with Old Town Road you
realize he's a real artist he had
exactly right intentional it's not a
Lucky Strike here that's not to see more
from him I'm so glad you said that and
if you look at his panini video I mean
it's so he's so creative how his mind
works is also very interesting he's a
really really really nice smart guy so I
was glad that they allowed us to come
and spend time he announced the other
day that he it's been a while seven
months he said on Twitter I'm ready to
take some time off so he's not going to
go to two upcoming
festivals but he promises that he will
make it up to his fans he's been working
burial all right take time off because
it's alive so much so fast it's a smart
choice so young he's only 20 he could
have been still yes 20 years old so yeah
take time
you got to heal your heart and your head